so i've been on the team with the bucks
for two years now
it's just a winning culture winning
environment everybody's
sacrificing for the team the name on the
front of the jersey
coming here we have championship
aspirations every possession
every game every rebound everything
matters here
early on in my career
i used to eat the wrong things fried
foods things like that
once you start getting older and once
you feel years in the league you start
to get a little smarter with your
regimen with your diet and things like
that so putting the right fuel in your
body
is vital and helps you perform at a high
level on the court
my game day routine obviously we have
shooting around on game days
i have to shoot around i would give my
shots up get in the ice tub take a
shower go home
eat put my norman tech on for 30 minutes
to hour and then i always have to have a
nap if i don't have a nap before my game
i'm just like a superstitious person i
feel like i have a bad game so
got to get a nap and then one of my
biggest superstitions is i have to put
my left shoe on before my right shoe
and tie my right shoe before my left
shoe
[Music]
my nutrition was very vital during my
hamstring injury
i was out 27 days couldn't work out can
only do treatment and rehab and things
like that
just eating the right nutritions
working on myself and susie working with
myself really helped me you know get
over the hump and cutting out some
things that i normally eat candies
you know drinking and things like that
just cutting those things out it helped
me get back to where i'm at now and you
know everything's trending in the right
direction
my favorite science and sports product
is
the hydro i drink it before practice
during practice when i'm at home
during the game so i can stay
you know ready and
just keep keep the right amount of
fluids in my body from day to day it's
very vital with the amount of minutes
that i'm logging right now to you know
stay in shape and also have the right
nutrition into my body